it's the bottom line by the way it's
what it is the Golden Globe nominations
have been announced and from Game of
Thrones two Watchmen Robert De Niro and
Lupita Nyong'o this morning was filled
with snubz and surprises and we're gonna
break them all down right now on the
ketchup some of the biggest surprises
for Monday's nominations were in the
form of snubz and that includes Game of
Thrones just a few months removed from
taking home 12 Emmys the show received
just one Golden Globe nominee Harrington
for Best Performance in a drama
and while HBO's latest hit watchman also
got zero noms the network can find
solace in the fact that the miniseries
Chernobyl is up for four awards in
perhaps the biggest shock among the film
nominations
Oscar favorite Robert DeNiro who many
considered a shoo-in for a Best Actor
nod for his work in the certified fresh'
gangster epic the Irishman well you
didn't make the cut but his two co-stars
Joe Pesci and Al Pacino earned
Supporting Actor nods I'm not afraid of
praise every night it takes another big
surprise from the world of film is that
Lupita Nyong'o one of our picks for the
best performance of 2019 has already
picked up for Best Actress trophies on
the awards circuit for her work in
Jordan pills certified fresh' US but
sadly was left off the list Monday
she played not one but two roles
flawlessly and still Noah stay in the
car lock the doors there are a few
notable surprises in the directing
category as well with Joker's Todd
Phillips getting a knob despite being
considered a bit of a long shot but that
came with the snub for marriage stories
Noah Baumbach and little woman's credit
Gerwig and that puts the total number of
women directors at gap zero this is
always a brutal categor
but it wasn't all snubz there were also
some very pleasant surprises as well
like the movie knives out which not many
expected to do so well on the awards
front picking up three nominations
including Best Picture Musical or Comedy
along with Ana de Armas and Daniel Craig
in the acting categories I suspect foul
play but perhaps the best surprise came
with the certified fresh' film Jojo
rabbit not only did it get a knob for
Best Picture Musical or Comedy or stoked
to see a nomination for Roman Griffin
Davis for Best Performance by an actor
the child stars going up against names
like DiCaprio Murphy and Craig and
that's pretty great especially knowing
what he told us about his award show
plan I understand about all the actors
are on how that already bugged them I
find a way to torture I'd pretend to be
like a waiter maybe who you lose to
people
and finally the 77th annual Golden Globe
Awards will air Sunday January 5th on
NBC and while the show itself is airing
on a major network not a single show
from a broadcast network will be
represented so in other words the cable
and streaming networks have officially
taken over and we must now all bow to
our binging overlords hey everything but
I want to know what do you think what
were your biggest surprises are you
excited for the Globes did Game of
Thrones deserve more love or are you
just glad that it's over let us know in
the comments section and for more awards
coverage head on over to Rotten Tomatoes
calm and if you don't want to miss out
on any future episodes or the catch-up
hit that subscribe button and the
notification bell thanks for watching
the ketchup I'm Jacqueline Kelly
[Music]